making his first big league start will
be the left-hander sammy long sammy long
from the sacramento area from fair oaks
california is 25 years of age 5 11 196
pounder
and you take your bats against him
you're going to see a fastball that's
low to mid 90s
a change up and a curveball all from a
high three quarter release and this
curveball is a very very good strikeout
pitch now bryce harper
[Applause]
high in the air
to medium deep right yastrinsky
inning over sammy long retires the
phillies without scoring tremski in the
bottom of the first yesterday hit a
two-run homer to put the giants ahead
that ball
high and deep to right field forget
about this one
off the pillar
as it was headed
for the cove a two-run homer two-nothing
giants well how do you hit a sinker ball
you look up that's exactly what happens
here he gets a belt high gift
and mike kastrimsky jumps all over it
and right side this field
is a short porch
this gets the hands inside it in the
barrel to the ball 2-2 pitch flores hits
a drive out to left center field and
this one's carrying well it is gone up
over the wall it kept going
giants go back to back
and they lead three nothing had a great
year last year hitting for a bunch of
power off right and left hand hitters he
was a bit fooled a bit out front on a
slider down but it does a good job
keeping his hands back and we're seeing
the ballpark i didn't think it was going
to play this lively i didn't think that
ball was going to get out but it had
some backspin and carried out into the
first row he's get to work here in the
third inning jt romneytow the battery he
had that double his first time up and
the lefties pitch swung on and hitting
the ears center field straight away
pretty deep duggar going back to the
track at the wall looking up and it is
gone
jt real muto with his seventh home run
of the season a two run bomb to straight
away center field and the phillies are
on the board it's a one-run game as the
giants lead 3-2
i literally was about to say but when's
the last time we saw jt had a big homer
feels like a while
and they tried to go fastball as they
beat him with the fastball all yesterday
again and
he's on time gets the foot up gets it
down
bushes
now brandon crawford to the play
crawford hit the first pitch
that he saw right back to effluent back
in the first inning
deep center
feeling back
warning drag one it's gone
and that's the third home run
of the game
for the giants and the 16th of the year
for brandon crawford
and that elusive
shutdown inning
again unattainable for the phillies here
he gets a little height on the sinker
again he's just not getting that pitch
down
there's a little bit of of hang to it
and crawford which he has done so many
times this year with his home run
hitting he takes on the deep part of the
yard
that just kept going and going he's home
run hitting giants wilmer flores who's
homered to left center and single to
left he's two for two
that ball is in the air deep left center
way back there goodbye
another home run for wilmer flores his
second of the game
and the giants fourth home run
today
like a change up and just
right middle in at the knees
and wilmer flora is just on lowe's
giants have been waiting for flores to
get hot and he is really starting to put
together a good swing
hopkins for the phillies who trail the
giants six to two and this oh to the
count
curveball struck him out looking now
when you could save it for a two-strike
surprise it's lethal and you can see the
arc on this thing and that is up there
as we mentioned barry zito
clayton kershaw that's that's that's a
big breaking ball
now bryce harper
that is the swing of the miss
harper is saying that he
got a piece of it but greg gibson said
no you didn't so
for the runner at first he is not
allowed to run with less than two out
but rio muto does take second take a
look at the
at the swing on the breaking ball gets
to the chase down below the strike zone
that's a change-up i beg your pardon
really has him way out front
serves his purpose
strikeout number six duggars hitting
seventh in the lineup so usually with
the eighth hit or ninth hitter coming up
ninth hitter being a pitcher
you might think drive this run in but
with a pinch hitter coming up now you
just want to get him over and he got the
bonus play he got to base it
solano heading home here's
duggar digging
and in the second with a double just
ahead of fearling's throw
seven to two giants
duggar probably the giants fastest
runner
he might have been upset he didn't get a
double off that one off the wall the
price played so good so he figured you
know what i'll make up for that with his
base hit up the middle
but if you look at the swing watch his
swing
again it's another change up that just
didn't do a whole lot but look at his
swing he had the intention of pulling
that ball no matter what but when it's
away like that that's where you hit it
if you're thinking pull he gets another
run and he gets himself in scoring
position
and the giants have the bases loaded for
donovan solano
boy
off of rio muto ustremski scores
eight to two giants
dubonda third crawford to second
take a look at how far out front this
this breaking ball is
oh it's three feet out for a whole play
you don't know the height of that
breaking ball when it's that far out in
front of you
he was in position to block it but he
never had a chance now curt casalli who
is one for three has singled struck out
a couple times having a real good week
with the bat
it's a bases loaded walk
to curt casalli
and the second run of the inning crosses
dubon scores
nine to two giants joe girardi comes out
with the hook for sam howard and hector
nearest he's going to uh come on here
the bases are loaded there's two outs
two straight singles to start the inning
the 2-2 offer and a swing and a miss he
struck him out tied him up and he
finally wins the battle with mike
talkman here's crawford
crawford's at a homer and a walk here's
the 1-0 crawford hits a high drive
center field
herrera back at the wall leaps and it's
off of his glove and then maybe off the
top of the wall and stays in play
duvan comes around third he'll score
here comes belt and he scores into
second
is brandon crawford with a double that
was
almost
his second home run of the day
11 to two giants david hale four seemed
fastball man that thing is center cut
and about five high and we've seen
crawford take one out of here at this
basically the same spot
oh hit off the top of the fence and did
it hit the double wow john the carom
went behind him crawford's got two hits
plus a walk a homer a double he's
knocked in four john brevia been a very
good pitcher and he's back on a big
league mound
and he's one out away from finishing off
a giants victory 11 to two giants here
in the ninth inning with two down
that nobody on
bribia strikes him out swinging stumbled
a little bit after throwing that pitch
but it worked out very well so his
giants debut sees him retire the side in
order and the giants do take this series
from the phillies